all right before we get started big
warning obviously a big warning this is
very inappropriate for literally anybody
this is a D monetization warning sound
the alarm there's gonna be no ads on
this one woop woop this is not for
children look at the [ __ ] very clearly
not for kids so anybody who has any sort
of weak stomach narrow Constitution wide
urethra I don't know just don't pay
attention to this game because it's
gonna get violent bloody and gory it is
a whack game in 2019 except this one
came out last year so it's 2018
technically when this came out but this
is whack the serial killer you know
whack the teacher or don't like the
teacher whack your boss all those things
this is one of the knockoffs of the
knockoff of those games yada yada either
way this one seems to be a more
intensive here we go burglars neighbors
creeps I think we've done all these
before this one the serial killer is new
and something that we've actually never
had a chance to do anymore so that's
what we're gonna do here and I imagine
it's not gonna go for good for anybody
no no not the trick not the old steak
trick whiskey oh oh well that's not good
uh-huh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay
yeah so last chance for everybody to
avert their eyes because it's about to
get horrifically bloody both for my
character and the serial killer I'm
guessing Am I oh hey good yeah yeah okay
well now I'm up and Adam so find all the
20 ways to kill the serial killer or
what they are so gonna do anything to me
chainsaw
yeah it seems it seemed safe excuse me
don't mind whoa okay maybe that didn't
work out as well as I thought it was
gonna work out oh hang on wait a minute
I didn't know I could lose it this
engagement I didn't know this is
something that I could you might want to
back up a little farther than that okay
oh good good boy Oh radical all right
cool good good you know I honestly
thought for a second than there actually
was gonna backfire on me and I wasn't
gonna survive that encounter but okay
all right good great great good okay
cool all right how about the rack I like
a good rack as much as the next person I
guess that's not the rack that's the
sledgehammer okay yeah that wouldn't
just cave in the skull that would knock
him out yeah that that's what that would
do just like a Gore horror movie that's
all this is it's just a cavalcade of
gratuitous violence for the sake of
violence yeah not radical just bloody
freedom freedom huh huh okay good glad
that happened well we got two downs just
gotta find oh good old iron maid and
that's always a fun one
that's always fun yeah okay you go for
the shovel first yeah I don't know how
that has to do with what that is but
okay cool yeah
[Laughter]
Oh easy-peasy oh yeah house new kill
thought yeah I know yeah I know I know
spooky I know I know I know I'm a toys
toys they gotta be fun right toys put
gummy wrong with toys oh those are not
fun toys Oh No that's your fault for
having that in your own basement not up
the pooper okay good at least it wasn't
up to Boober okay six orbs woody I'm
tiny and hook-hand
and oh you're still oh no you're not
alive like little fairies they just
disappear into the ether all right good
great I guess what are we not escaping
we're just gonna watch that yeah you
know actually I kind of agree with you
maybe you don't need to go anywhere for
the shotgun perfect that a double-barrel
pump-action shotgun oh hell yeah
yep for some reason it's a
double-barreled pump-action yeah hey
don't turn around maybe you shouldn't
have turned around buddy
[Music]
okay all right you know good job good
job good job good job
good on you good job great jorb there
Ham stray god I haven't played one of
these games it'll log that bag of
feathers this object requires a second
to work bag of feathers is there any tar
of course tar and feathers man you think
I'd take off the high heels for sneaking
but this guy seems to be really really
death huh
what all right well not so bad
what what what what why this mystery I
would be burning what I met yes it was a
lot of those a lot of working pieces to
get to that moment there sure electric
chair yeah Oh electric chair plus I
don't know bucket of water some bear
trap surgery tools no fire rope OH
rope rope apparently why there's a rope
or electric all right there you go buddy
hey how you doing hey maybe you
shouldn't have been a serial killer I
guess
[Music]
I'm not seeing how the Rope plays into
all this we-we-we wall we will all right
still don't see where the rope came into
play here what did you use the rope for
whatever I've gotten seven only seven
okay Malik plus rules vise and saw well
ah I like a vampire I'm gonna stake him
through the hard I'm just gonna yeah
yeah yeah yeah get him yeah get right oh
yeah perfect just for good measure
yeah what a mess what a mess guillotine
a Gill a guillotine I love it the flying
head smack yeah wake up I didn't have
the machete But Here I am
[Music]
well alright then I guess our work here
is done alright can of pain
I know how this is gonna work unless
you're gonna drown him in the canopy
maybe you can paint his nails and he
really doesn't like it maybe he's
allergic to pain are you just gonna hit
him with it or you're just gonna hit him
with it
you didn't even use the paint
use the paint at all
wood stove + mallet rope or bear trap
back there we go good calm bro
all right here we go gonna chop some
firewood yeah all right well yeah he is
dead what did you use the fire for oh
he's not dead
somehow okay okay this is just
unnecessarily that's brutal in another
this is pretty brutal pretty brutal
pretty what one would call brutal okay
yep alright yeah how's he breathing
huh how do I still here how did I still
here what kind of devil magic happened
in here I gotta say this serial killers
not good at his job
I guess you could call this his job
right that's that's what this is how
about the rope electrical cords plus oh
wait no that's that it wasn't rope it
was lecturing cords
okay stacks aw good old Hacksaw
everybody loved it oh I'm just gonna use
the stick seems to be surprisingly
effective
wait where did I get a bomb good thing
there's 52 hours on that timer and that
timer is so much time on it and let me
guess is still gonna blow up I mean I
get the saw
reference is he gonna blow up you're
gonna blow up okay it's not gonna blow
up okay no blowing up okay no blow up
just explode yeah that way Freddie's
glove sure don't know why he has these
but all right here we go yeah good Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
watch out pop okay good great good great
good good good good good great good how
many have we found 13 and we're doing
great guys well feel good about myself
bear trap time do it let's do this yep
gotta get to for what I'm about to do
man this guy is deaf this guy's so dead
yeah okay Oh
[Music]
oMFG yeah well one must forgive Gus I
say that on my own as well
Kage plus would naturally go with a
caged bird feathers brick no yep tried
everything every night unless I'm
missing something
aah-ha-ha-ha
found you that's again neither of the
things that I said to you alright
that's just too brutal I like the flying
tackle with the wood a little bit more
than that again on the wreck that's not
the cage
okay that's Oh oh my god that one was
probably the worst yeah it's bad it's
bad on multiple levels okay so I'm
assuming that one combo leads to another
combo propane tank this one's got to be
fun this one's got the again that's not
what I gave to you that's not the
propane bag that's that's a sledgehammer
okay oh oh I see
all right OH
[Laughter]
oh god I don't think that's oh okay
Girish yeah I you know I guess he was
gonna kill you but at a certain point
just becomes quite sadistic Rick oh oh
oh what what
[Music]
okay I've never actually seen the movie
with like that character in it I forget
what he's even called I didn't know his
nips were exposed like that are his nips
exposed like that I mean his nips look
like they've been ripped off but is that
what's the key yeah let's go hey can you
please let me out of here bud oh my god
wait oh fail I'm sorry I didn't know
that was an option does that count
amongst my kills no it does not okay how
about the surgical tools and here comes
the fly tackle
oh my god you are alright what happens
if you get through it all oh they throw
a long story short nothing happened I
discovered this through sheer trial and
error discovered this all right vice
time time for the vise let's go baby
Wang I don't know if this is just gonna
be the head and the vise or maybe the
testicles in the vise no ahead in the
vise
Oh No
oh no oh no oh god oh no oh god oh no
okay right you've unlocked the final
hidden kill oh good great that plus key
right no that plus ax to chop it knife
to pick it here we go
Oh Kroeber crowbar wasn't there before
was it I don't know I don't think so
hi-yah oh it's hello what's your name
I see all right okay now yeah I thought
it was the dude now watch out cuz things
about to get bloody doing doing
[Music]
oh wait I didn't know this bus to
participate in this I didn't know that I
was an active participant here oh yeah
click oh yeah click oh epic combo oh
[Music]
yeah go white why does it have to be the
balls okay good ouch
puppy you could put those down at any
time all right you gonna finish this
chapter get ready for more kills good
you know I'm good I think that I'm good
you know there's only so many this game
you know you could do in a year and I
have waited over a year to play the next
one so I think I'm good so yeah thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want this it's two bucks on Steam
and hey you get all these cool games fun
fun fun fun games fun fun fun fun fun
game mmm so if you made it to the end of
this consider it a challenge that you
won so congratulations to you nothing
else to say about it other than to say
it so if you want to see the other games
in this series that I've played the
other various gratuitous violence once
because you know a long time ago the
originals they weren't so bloody I mean
yeah they were bloody and violent on
some of them but others were just like
imaginative weird
ethereal ways to do it from this one
creator of the game but you know it is
what it is but thank you everybody so
much for watching link to the playlist
of all these videos is in the
description below if you want to see him
this price I'm gonna suggested over
there let me know if you want to see
more I don't know if there's more to see
but if there are let me know and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]